ce mardi avait lieu la vère nationale
des assistants d'éducation partent en
france des collectifs déterminée contre
la précarité général du métier exacerbée
à par le contexte sanitaire
les assistants d'éducation refusent
d'être la police du masque dans les
collèges dans les lycées
à paris quelques tensions en fin d'après
midi entre policiers et manifestants des
manifestants qui ont exprimé leur
frustration est telle et plusieurs
revendications dont la titularisation
les primes seraient plus que l'on ne
touche pas les statuts et voilà grosso
modo c'est ce qui est revendiqué la
situation dans les collèges est pourri
mon âge moyen et on n'a pas de moyens
qui sont à la hauteur des problèmes on
un métier qui est demandé par la
fonction est quasiment doublé c'est à
dire que l'on va faire un travail de
surveillance ont fait quasiment le même
travail que certains policiers dehors
sauf qu'on n'a pas envie de faire ça ce
contrat avec des enfants et donc la plus
fait majoritairement de la surveillance
et a énormément de bagarre il ya aussi
des élèves qu'on équilibre dans des
conditions horribles avec des simplement
leurs relations avec leurs parents qui
sont très tendues donc le caractère
ensuite convoi gérer nos quotidiens elle
et il n'est pas facile non plus donc
assistants d'éducation et là aussi
parfois pour refaire leur éducation pour
leur expliquer que dans lundi ça
marchera pas comme ça concernant ensuite
le
le salaire moi je suis un temps partiel
heureusement que j'ai la bourse à côté